the real key
to success
and to being an effective content
marketer
is to say whatever tactic i'm using if
it's a newsletter if it's an in-person
event if it's
an illustration or photo you know you
name it
am i using it as effectively as i could
and that's the key
that's the key
many of these tactics i've used over the
years
and one of the things we've learned is
that
you can again check something off the
left list and say ah have you done x
and you can say yeah i did x
and if you do it and you do it uh
in a ineffective way you can certainly
say you did it
but it doesn't move the needle
so one of the things that we're going to
share with you in this module
is not just the list
so you can make sure okay in my content
marketing
campaign you know
how many things have i done
how many boxes have i ticked off we're
going to talk about each one of them
in a way that can help you
use it
more effectively
whether you use this entire list or part
of the list
it doesn't matter whatever you do use
let's make sure you're using it
effectively so i want to start off with
one of the tactics that's been on
this list for
well over five years and it's always at
the top if it's not number one it's
number two
and it's a surprise for some people
because it's email newsletters
which is a really really old tactic
email newsletters have been around for
20 years
and
one of the things that i hope this sort
of illustrates
is it doesn't matter whether it's the
new bright shiny thing that just got
unveiled last week
or it's been around for 20 years
you know some things have been around 20
years because they still
work
and people have a learning curve and
they've learned how to make them work
even more effectively
or as in the case of email newsletters
they've gone through purgatory as
things like
gmail
changed the rules of uh
how
email gets delivered
and
you've you've had to go back and rethink
what you're doing
and the net net is
the folks who are doing email marketing
and are using email newsletters
effectively
have made the appropriate adjustments
so
what are the keys to being successful
with this tactic well first of all you
want to foster a sense of belonging in
other words
there are some email newsletters i look
to
receiving every morning
and if they are delayed for some reason
it's like i'm missing them it's like
wait a second how come that hasn't come
in yet
um
that's not true
of every email newsletter
um and that expectation
that
i rely on this i want to receive it
and let me give you a real life example
i subscribe to
the boston globe
newspapers newsletter
now i also get the print edition
delivered to my home
but i get the email
version a couple of hours actually
before the print version is delivered on
my doorstep
and i tend to get up early in the
morning and i rely on that it gives me a
sort of uh the news of the day what's
important uh in my area
and i can concentrate on that
before quote starting
um the day um to do work for uh my
company or my clients
well
it was late this morning
i knew it it's it's like where did
where is it
and that sense of
this is essential reading for me
is
is something that you need to strive to
achieve if you're going to be using
newsletters effectively
and the reason you can get there is
dependent on the content
if all you're doing is uh
regurgitating uh the latest press
releases from your company
you know that's not particularly
compelling
if you are providing insights and useful
tips
um and uh the latest trends
now you've got something now you've got
something so again content
is key
and
it's not just the newsletter delivery
format which still works
but you know the key is putting the
effort into thinking what are the
various articles going to be so provide
exclusive content
or some benefits that can't be found
anywhere else
that's the key to making this tactic
work
and yes you know you can do some
progressive profiling you can try to
figure out if some people are more
interested in some areas of your
newsletter than others and you know
perhaps that's an opportunity for you to
tailor specific messages to
segments of your subscriber list
all of that is useful all of that is
best practice and all of that then takes
this tactic
to the highest level of issues another
item that has always been at the top of
uh these lists of effective tactics uh
at least in all the research that i've
seen
are in-person events and there are some
marketers out there that say wait a
second isn't this digital marketing
aren't we supposed to be focused
on things that are happening online
and the answer is for content marketers
yes
a lot of content that you'll be creating
is digital
but a face-to-face event
if it is still the most effective tool
in your arsenal
and research indicates that for a lot of
people it is
then put the effort into thinking about
it
in other words you can quote have a
trade show booth
and it can be there on the trade show
floor
and a few people may walk by it
occasionally and you can say well i was
there
and the answer is no no that that that's
not particularly effective is it
when we have exhibited at uh trade shows
or conferences
one of the things that we work on really
hard
is to make sure that either we have
speakers
from the company or brand uh who are um
also on the
conference side of the event
or if we don't have enough speakers uh
to sort of make sure that our message is
is getting out or the stories that we
want to tell are being told
then we identify who the speakers are
at that conference who might
be interested in receiving information
from us ahead of time
it could be
you know new research data that we have
some new case studies that we're willing
to share
and what we have seen is when we work
that event effectively
people come out of those sessions and
then come down to our trade show booth
and say i just heard about you in the
last session tell me what you got
okay so that is working the event
effectively
and again you know there's lots of ways
to keep that conversation going
and um it's the beginning of building a
relationship so it's not just about
collecting their business cards and
and saying how big is the list
you know um
let them know i you know i can continue
keeping you updated uh would you like to
receive our newsletter
and there's a lot of things that you can
do with those conference presentations
that you've given
you can
we'll get to this later in this session
you can put them online you can put them
on slideshare
and it doesn't always have to be about
your presentations if somebody else
gives a really good presentation
that actually you know makes a key point
about your
category or market
and
doesn't necessarily even have to mention
you
you know sometimes that's worth
highlighting and featuring as well it
may be the beginning of building a
relationship
with that speaker so again
take advantage of the events that are
part of your strategy
just because they're not digital doesn't
mean they shouldn't be integrated into
what you're what you're thinking
a
speech
at a conference
is content
all right i i'm a former speechwriter so
we put great thought
into what an executive was going to say
at a particular uh event uh it was
always customized we didn't have the the
same speech that we recycled over and
over and over again
because we wanted to take advantage of
that unique opportunity
to deliver that piece of content and
you know you should take that advice as
well now social media content has been
all the rage for years and years and so
it's not surprising that b2b and b2c
marketers rate it as something that they
want to use as a tactic um
uh it it has been and and i know in some
organizations it's like wait a second
you know the social media group is down
the hall there's somebody else um i
don't want to try it on their toes the
answer is no the social media people
down the hall shouldn't be down the hall
they should be all part of the content
marketing uh effort
their content is one of the ways that
you can you can reach out to a variety
of audiences
and make sure that each one of those
platforms those social media platforms
that you're using
are effectively communicating
the company's message
they shouldn't be islands to themselves
if you've got for example
a youtube channel it shouldn't be
detached
from the content marketing effort they
shouldn't be creating
videos on some subject that's unrelated
to what your content marketing mission
is all about
and yes different platforms work
different ways so you may want to create
different kinds of content although
if you step back and look at the trends
it turns out once upon a time the only
place you really put video was on
youtube it turns out over the last
couple of years facebook has
aggressively gotten into the video field
and so you certainly want to
include videos on your facebook platform
twitter has followed suit so guess what
you're going to want to think about the
videos that you've got on twitter
etc etc
you can share videos to pinterest
um you can share videos to linkedin
you can you can create videos on
instagram
so again um
yes there are differences between the
platforms but increasingly
visual content is becoming
a a key in all of those
and
every now and then
it's it's good to try something that you
haven't done before
and
if you do it on a small scale it's a
test
uh even if it doesn't work you've just
learned something okay that didn't work
we won't do that again
uh and that is a little hard for people
in business to do is to say well wait a
second you know i
you want me to deliberately fail no
i want you to deliberately try something
you haven't done before
that you know in business you know every
now and then you've got to sort of test
the boundaries um you've got to test the
assumptions that you're making
and you can do that
and as long as it is a test where you
measure the results then you're not just
doing stuff
you know willy nilly
you were actually
exploring you know did i get a higher
than expected uh response rate
when i did that is this a tactic that i
may want to do some more and the only
way you're going to find out is if
you're always conducting tests a lot of
b2b marketers think timeout you know
that's a b2c tactic
and the answer is sometimes it is
but i will tell you linkedin
which is often overlooked in b2c
marketing
is a perfect spot for a social media
content campaign
in b2b
the people who linkedin attracts are all
business professionals
and one of the things that we've done
successfully uh again and again and this
is an example of it here
we do work with uh
the rutgers school of management and
labor relations so it's smlr
they wanted to reach out to human
resource
professionals
particularly the ones that could send
groups of students from a company
to attend courses at rutgers
so this is a business-to-business kind
of situation
and this was put together by the uh what
is called epe or the executive and
professional education
uh
group within uh rutgers smlr
and so how do you get those folks
well they're that's that's all
it's not something you can do a lot of
cold calling on that's that's that's
hard but what we did instead is we
created a linkedin group
and we asked the hard question what
would a busy professional
uh want to do on linkedin um what would
they want access to
that would have them join a group
because we're all busy people
and what we decided was the the key
piece of content
that people would kill for was research
particularly if you've got the latest
research on let's say workforce
developments
so that's what we created a linkedin
group around and we said by the way
we're going to set this up yes we're
rutgers yes we're smlr yes we're at epe
we're not trying to pretend we're not
but what we really want to do is to
share with you some of the latest
research but get your feedback on it
what do you think did we ask the right
questions are you seeing other
developments in the industry that we've
missed and over an incredibly short
period of time we built that community
to more than 2 000 members
all of whom are the right target
audience because you
wouldn't be interested in this topic if
you weren't a member of the right target
audience
and they are contributing and they are
interacting and they are building
relationships and along the way
they are discovering that oh
rutgers is offering some new kinds of
courses i didn't know about
and this might be something worth
sending some of my students to one of
the most recent ones that we were
promoting
had to do with women executives learning
how to break through the glass ceiling
well think about that anyone who's in hr
is wrestling with that issue oh you
started a new program um to tackle that
tough problem cool
cool i know some um
women executives uh
at a junior level who i want to make
sure get the kind of development they
need to to go forward well that's how
you then
basically leverage content
in a social media platform
that generates leads
it's doable it's doable it's just stop
thinking about it this is just simply
you know we tried twitter it didn't work
you know this is you know think about it
again social media content can be
incredibly effective
particularly if you put the thought into
it and uh and take it to the next level
this is something that has come on in
the last couple of years
in terms of its popularity and its
effectiveness
and their online presentations and i i
know
many of us
give powerpoint presentations all the
time and unfortunately most powerpoint
sucks i mean i can't put it more mildly
than that
it
if you've got a bad
presentation
putting it online is not magic it
doesn't suddenly transform into
something that is much more interesting
on the other hand
if you've got a really compelling
presentation one that
one of your executives used and people
really responded to
putting it online now takes that
effective communication device
and expands the audience and how far can
you expand the audience let me give you
this example
um it's the
2016 internet trends report that mary
meeker presented in june uh of 2016.
it's her latest trends in the industry
there are 213
slides it is not a short presentation
but look at this
over 1.7
million people
have downloaded this presentation
i downloaded this presentation
i
wrote a blog post for one of the blogs
that i write for because the the data in
this is so rich
and i basically said you know even if
you don't have time to read all 213
slides here are the 10
that you absolutely positively have to
know about
so again you know
something that a lot of people don't
think about
should probably be part of your content
marketing mix
and again you can use slideshare it's
got over 70 million users
you definitely want to make sure that
your title slide which is what people
will see first grabs people's attention
it helps if you've got a story that
you're telling
now mary's happens to be longer and more
detailed than most
but guess what it's sort of organized
into four key trend areas and so you can
you can understand
the arc of even her long presentation
and
sometimes you want to emphasize imagery
over text
but it doesn't hurt to have text there
too i
as you can see by my style that i've got
here in this presentation i've got the
image i find that that's sort of the
right balance
and make sure if you're going to create
one of these that you've got a clickable
call to action link in your slides
it can be near the end if you want
that will take you to a landing page on
your website
if people are interested in more
information on
this presentation this trend
you know
this new product announcement whatever
it is that you're you're unveiling
this is a really effective tactic to to
be using now microsites is another
tactic that people have used from time
to time there are a number of companies
a number of brands that have used
microsites incredibly effectively so
it's an option it may not be
something that you want to use every
time but it's one that you ought to be
able to think about and know when and
how to use it when it happens and
and the example i'm trying to show here
is one of called shara coke
this was a campaign that actually was
tested initially in australia
it was so successful it then rolled out
across the rest of the world
and what they basically said is um
don't just buy our product which is what
everybody says right
what they said is
if you want you can um
buy this coca-cola and it'll have a
message on it and the message here was
either you know
you're the best mom
or you're my best friend forever
or they even went on to customize it so
this is for the williams family
and you know what um it it got right
down to where you could um
address it
for an individual name
and uh yeah there was a cost associated
with this customization
but it turned out people were willing to
pay the cost
that was the surprise that's why it
started off as a microsite this is not
something that you wanted to
you know
launch broadly in day one so the
microsite was actually a clever clever
way to test to see if this would work
let's go down and see if it works in
australia if it does then we can roll it
out if it doesn't well you know
it's not there on the home page of the
main site okay so so again
clever strategy
and
in this case because it's a microsite
you don't have to appeal to all of your
different
customer segments you can
pick one or two key personas
you know
let's see if it works here before we
come up with variations on this theme
it really helps if the microsite has
some
features in it that will drive
participation in some way because of all
you can tell
is oh by the way i got so many people
visited this microsite
um
okay well what would have happened if
they had visited the main site instead
in others
go beyond the traffic
make sure that whatever you're creating
has other
goals
than just a visit
and make sure that if again this is
targeted
keep it focused
and if you've attracted an audience
don't abandon them
you're now committed to this microsite
you're going to have to keep it year
after year after year
you know you you can't walk away from it
so it's going to become a permanent part
of your portfolio
so think about all of that but this is a
tactic you might want to consider and
blogs are key if you don't have a blog
as part of your b2c and b2b
content marketing program start one if
you have one go and check out what
you're doing
because there are a lot of people who
say you need a blog and they
added a blog
and if you look at it this blog isn't
worth reading
you know what uh we tried to do this on
the cheap you know we post occasionally
and what we post is
only about us and by the way it's not
particularly interesting
so it's not good enough to say i got a
blog
make sure that this one sizzles
make sure that if you've got content in
it that your headlines aren't killing
the potential for somebody to click on
that headline and read the full post
it it turns out most people will scan
your headline and decide whether to read
it or not so put the extra effort into
your headline
make sure that you know there are a lot
of people who are going to be busy
so summarize the main point at the
beginning of your post so they can get
the gist of it and figure out you know
is this worth reading or
um do i want to back out of here right
now let them know what you're going to
tell them
um reinforce your message with images uh
in the post it's it's impossible for me
to turn in a blog post these days to any
of the clients that i work with or for
or even some of the blogs that i just
write for without an image my editor
will turn it back and say where's the
image it's you know
and sometimes i can be a video instead
of
a photo but there isn't a post these
days that i can i can write where uh i
don't have to spend some time thinking
about the graphic that goes with it
make sure that you've like restated key
points in a bulleted list particularly
near the end where let's say you're
summarizing the key takeaways
make sure you're using subheads as
you're not just regurgitating a bunch of
content
and summarize uh at the end uh you know
provide a conclusion
that then can take the content that
you're delivering and make it digestible
and so the point here isn't to i've
written some blog posts why i wrote one
a week last year
yeah
how many of them are memorable
how many did people take action on uh
how many uh
you know generated leads that we hadn't
seen before
that's a whole different level that you
need to take your blog to
for it to be effective
now this may be a surprise
print
magazines again you know in a digital
world that we're living in pardon me
you're telling me print works i thought
print was dead
well the answer is it's not dead yet it
may die someday but it's not dead yet
and the example that i've shown here is
actually the oldest content marketing
campaign that is still
running because it's still working
the furrow was launched uh in
1895.
and it provided
basically farmers with
practical advice and how to get more out
of their farming
and it was made by the people
who made plows
okay
um and they wanted you to buy their plow
but you know how much can you tell
people about a plow
um to sort of differentiate it from the
quote other plows that they
might have purchased instead well
what what john deere did was to say yeah
yeah we've got great plows but guess
what we're also going to tell you how to
use them more effectively
and that
basically differentiated in them in the
market that's why the company is still
around all these years later it's why
the magazine is still around all these
years later and if you want to subscribe
to the magazine
you can't
you have to go to a john deere
uh dealer
in order to get access to the magazine
because john deere wants to use it as a
way of getting people to walk into
basically a place that can sell them a
plow
or
in these days you know modern farming
equipment
so again you know
just because it print its print doesn't
mean it's dead
make sure that if you're going to design
a magazine like this
that you've got someone designing it who
has experience
and make sure that it's a visual and
you're taking advantage of
the magazine
format
make sure that the articles that you're
writing
are relevant
uh you know
it needs to be on topic whatever your
topic happens to be
and
it also helps if there is a digital
version that's easily available
um in in in this case it's only
available if you have the subscription
but then the subscription gives you
uh with a password access to the digital
version
why
because guess what the farmers who are
out in the fields uh plowing
uh have smartphones and there was that
article that i read the other day
you know and they can get access to it
in their tractor um from their
smartphone so again you know uh the
world may evolve but uh some tactics
continue to work year after year decade
after decade books work i know i know
this is the digital age
you know but guess what amazon.com
taught all of us that guess
people still want to read books
who knew
well i i've written books this is
this is the second edition of youtube
and video marketing
you know books work
now
i can hear some of you
saying you got to be kidding me i don't
have time to write a book
and so there are ways to write books
you know sometimes you need a co-author
um
that's one way to do it
i found the time to write a book by
writing it on weekends
and so i structured the time with my uh
publisher as such that i'm going to turn
in a chapter
you know
um
basically uh
a a chapter a month
and that then gave me uh four weekends
to write parts of that chapter
and you know over the course of uh about
10 months i was able to put together a
book
so
again it's it's not trivial uh it's not
something you can easily knock off
but um
guess what
a lot of people say oh wow you've
written books you know you must be an
expert in this field
well
it helps if you're an expert when you
write a book
if you write a book and you're not an
expert it's going to show pretty quickly
i have some friends who have written
versions of books for
the dummies series so
the dummies guide to you know
whatever
and interestingly enough they're experts
it's actually
harder for an expert to dumb stuff down
than it is for the expert to speak in
the experts jargon and assume everyone
else is going to catch up to them so
whatever
books are a great tactic um
the key though even if you self-publish
is to have a great editor
and by the way uh
despite what you've heard uh you can't
judge a book by its cover people do
judge books by their cover so you know
if there's one place that you really
really really want to focus on make sure
that you've got a killer cover design
and it helps if you've got a series
yeah it's hard enough to write a book
but guess what my book was part of the
hour a day series
so mine was youtube and video marketing
an hour a day there's also facebook
marketing in our day
there is pinterest marketing an hour a
day there is web analytics an hour etc
etc etc in other words it was part of a
series so people who wanted to
learn about video could do that they
could read my book but they could read
my colleague's book
um on a related topic and so again you
know
that is a another way of sort of
making sure that you're you know
you know they bundled four of our books
together and sold it uh
as a set um um and that's because it was
part of a series so you know think about
that it's uh it's a really effective
tactic if you want to establish your
authority or your credibility or your
expertise
uh in a particular area
ebooks is another interesting tactic
that has emerged uh
over the last couple of years for b2b
marketers
and they are shorter than writing a full
book which can take you nine months or
more to write i know because i've
written books
but um i've participated in ebooks uh in
in writing them
and um
one of the ways we did that was we got
eight different experts together each
one of us contributed a chapter that
then got collected by the publisher who
put out an ebook and you know what it's
a heck of a lot easier reading a chapter
than writing a full book
and for the person who may download the
ebook it's like wow you know the
thoughts of eight different experts on
this particular topic you know that's
you know
even better
so again you can you can create these uh
they can be very effective
and
again you can use them for lead
generation you know if if you want you
can give the ebook away for free you
know that's fine
make sure that there is a link
um particularly near uh the end of the
ebook so that if people finish they can
click on the link and come back to
a page on your website where they can
get more information
or see the other ebooks that you've also
published whatever
but you can also basically put them
behind a
lead registration form if you want our
free ebook terrific just fill out this
form most people understand
that process these days they'll respond
to it
and you know collect the information you
need in order to qualify
your prospects your sales force will
hate it if you just dump a lot of names
on them uh without any indications of
excuse me
you know where are they in the buying
cycle you know what kind of budget do
they have so there's there's some
information you may want to have in the
form uh to make sure that when someone
downloads your ebook
that you're helping to qualify the
prospect that you're going to have
somebody either in tele sales or
you know face-to-face sales follow up
with
but guess what e-books work
e-books work as a as a as an effective
tactic virtual conferences is another
thing that sort of popped up recently uh
in the to-do list for some b2b marketers
um
i have to say i've attended a couple
one was
really a well
organized event and good use of my time
um the other not so much so you know
this is this is an area where you know
maybe the people who are putting
together virtual conferences are still
trying to
invent the wheel
maybe after it gets invented
the wheel will get you where you want to
go a little more frequently
but if you're going to put one of these
on
if you're going to organize one for your
company
make sure to book and confirm the
speakers as early as possible the one
that i went to that was not so
successful was getting the speakers
posted at the last minute
well pardon me you know
if i'm gonna block out some time to
attend one of these things even if it's
online
i gotta know that it's gonna be worth my
time so
that was uh a knee capper right from the
beginning
and again you know it's still early days
for these things you're gonna have to
double and triple check your technology
just to make sure that people who attend
your virtual conference can get into it
and realize that
it's not just about the time zone you
live in people will attend a virtual
conference from anywhere around the
world
so your opening hours and your closing
hours may need to
get adjust
adjusted accordingly
and you know provide some way to extend
that experience if you're going to put
all the effort into creating one of
these things
make sure that people who can't attend
it in real time as it's happening
can get access to archived versions of
it again if they register and give you
their contact information
and and and you know again this may not
be one of the first tactics that you
want to use
but it may be an appropriate tactic to
use
in certain circumstances
[Music]
hey want to become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here